it is a very tight very detailed
evidence-laden uh indictment and the
contact in there is is awful
I mean put aside taking the documents in
the first place
but then when you start getting asked
Anderson in May of 21
nicely with a letter from the archivist
saying could you please give it back
and you ignore it ignore it ignore it
then they come with a grand jury
subpoena and then according to the
indictment you tell your lawyers tell
them we don't have anything even though
you have dozens and dozens of boxes of
material that's obstruction of justice
if it's true this is an actual proper
legal analysis from a prosecutor who is
not so blinded by partisanship and he
also has an incentive to criticize Trump
obviously